octobre 2001 au quartier de la grange
aux belles dans le 10e arrondissement
c'était qu'il nous ferait ch après midi
de tonnes à un cours de ps j'étais en
ce1
alors mes camarades enchaîner les tours
de piste mais moi je boitille encore sur
le premier jeu souffrait le martyre à
chaque pas la fatigue d'un marathonien
dans le corps d'un enfant comme un
symbole je tombe c'est fini me disent
tout bas
un lit notamment j'espérais qu'un super
héros que je ne ratais jamais à la
télévision ou à une intervention divine
ne vienne en aide
mais pas cette fois pas cette voie non
jambes en coton
quand en carton mon rêve de devenir
zinedine zidane comme tous les gamins à
mon âge il faut donc froidement
c'est donc une nouvelle ville un nouveau
rapport que ce doit apprivoiser avec mon
fauteuil roulant tout est trop à présent
mon nutella préféré mon jus de pomme ou
vous encore mes tartines préféré alors
je développe un nouveau rapport avec un
autre objet la lecture n'étant pas trop
dans les habitudes de la maison la
télévision bizarrement cet objet me
fascine et je me fais donc un programme
un programme tf1 l'après-midi france dès
le matin entrecoupé par des débats
politiques des matchs de foot
bref la télévision à ce pouvoir
d'envoûtement sur moi et elle ne me
quittera jamais l'homme qui a clairement
fait naître
ma vocation de journaliste c'est thierry
indices ont alors tiré addition au début
du 21e siècle
clem dernière g3
il est présenté tout le monde en parle
une émission un talk show qui passaient
tous les samedis en deuxième partie de
soirée et cette émission le cd rêver
voilà tous ces artistes philosophes ces
acteurs qui venaient présenter leurs
oeuvres m'ouvrait d'autres horizons à
chaque fois avec laurent baffie qui
faisait des vannes qui faisait délirer
d'ailleurs le lendemain je m'amusais
toujours avec de plus un batman qui
représentait dire à des sons et une
peluche à lourches qui faisait laurent
banide les faits j'ai dialogué tous les
deux et je me suis dit cette culture
d'une interview cette méthode me
fascinait me donnait vraiment envie de
continuer
le véritable tournant a élu le jour de
mes dix ans
ma maman me disait yanis c'est quoi ton
vous dit mais non j'ai pas te le dire
sinon on veut ne négligera pas dit mais
qu'il est moi vraiment yanis 10 le mois
il a je lis dans l'oreille maman je rêve
d'être journaliste sportif commentateurs
voir que ce que je ne peux pas
transmettre en étant footballeur et ben
je vais ça ressentir mais l'émotion aux
gens qui me regarderont et qui
l'écouteront elle me disait qui sera ma
tête et je serai t jambes à a2 on va
essayer de faire en sorte que tu
deviennes journalistes on va essayer et
cette phrase-là de la mer ce duo qu'on a
formé par la suite a été pour moi
quelque chose d'extraordinaire parce que
je lui dois tout et je n'aurais rien
fait sans elle
c'est pourquoi tous les matins quand
aujourd'hui plus là je lui remercier
encore de tout qu'elle a fait pour moi
par la suite
j'aurai une scolarité normale j'ai eu un
bac littéraire
j'ai étudié ensuite dans cette maison en
droit en un faucon en information
communication et parallèlement à ça il
fait une rencontre qui a changé ma vie
celle avec grégoire margotton la voie
des bleus qui travaillait auparavant à
canal+ que j'ai rencontrés un soir de
match au stade de france
en tribune présidentielle ne me demandez
pas comment j'ai réussi à pénétrer là
dedans c'est inavouables et grégoire
justement j'ai dû le souder pendant une
heure et demie de blagues lourdes et
inutile je pense qu'il a dû prix tous
les dieux du monde de l'univers pour que
ce match se termine au plus vite pour se
séparer de moi j'ai quand même réussi à
l'attraper à la phobie lisant s'cusez
moi monsieur vous n'avez pas installé
pour moi la rentrée et là il me tend sa
carte et me dit rappelle moi à la fin de
l'été on verra alors bien souvent pour
les gens qui sont familiers du monde des
médias
on verra veut dire non votre très
glamour ça veut dire non mais j'ai quand
même tenté tenté de le relancer entre
septembre et la belle histoire à canal
elle a commencé comme ça par un d'abord
des petits montages suite des petites
villes tard view des petits micros
trottoirs
par la suite deux plus grands reportages
et qu'elle m'a donné ma chance et je
pense que c'était pas évident pour eux
de mettre à l'écran une personne
handicapée
mais j'ai toujours eu ce leitmotiv
car c'était mon rêve et je n'avais pas
le droit de décevoir tous ceux qui m'ont
fait confiance et surtout
j'ai toujours au figés l'autocensure
nous tous sens sur k7 influent encore
plus grave que la discrimination car
c'est une barrière qu on se suit
chamelle finalement on s'empêche soi
même le faire de grandes choses et il ya
eu cette notion par la suite de qui ce
bac de rendre aux autres ce qu'on m'a
donné de donner aux autres vraiment et
comme par hasard en début d'année
dernière
l'uefa m'a contacté car il cherchait des
jeunes journalistes pour commenter
l'euro 2016 pour les personnes aveugles
sur les principes qu'ils aient trouvé
cela génial car ça faisait directement
écho aux vous que j'avais fait quand
j'avais 10 ans quand j'avais dit à ma
mère maman je veux transmettre des
émotions et c'est ce que je fais
plusieurs week-ends par an commenté des
mac et d'écrire des actions transmettre
ce que je ressens en voyant un match de
foot à des personnes aveugles
finalement je me suis toujours dit à
défaut de pouvoir courir aussi vite que
les autres qu'il ait tenté de réfléchir
aussi vite voire plus vite que les
autres
mais il a fallu pour cela est fort ça
m'a forgé un mental d'acier et j'ai
toujours cru en l'école de la république
en la méritocratie à condition d'en
faire deux trois à quatre fois plus que
les autres en me disant toujours que la
victoire on serait que plus belle
enfin un jour nous intervenons dans un
collège de zep en classe un jeune homme
me dit oui mais sciences po c'est pas
fait pour moi
alors pour y avoir étudié ont été
diplômés de cette grande école le midi
mais t'as pas le droit de dire ça t'as
pas le droit parce que dole mot
impossible si tu décompose ce mot en
anglais
ta iam possible alors il comprenait pas
trop mais je lui ai dit que les
ressources
il les avait en lui finalement quand se
motivant qu'en croyant que c'était
possible qu en étant persuadé que cela
était possible
ils allaient pouvoir y arriver et tant
pis s'il allait rater ils allaient
retenter quelque chose d'autre mais au
moins il sera allé jusqu'au bout de son
rêve
c'est pour cela que si j'avais quelque
chose à vous transmettre ce serait 12
les doses et dévoiler vos talent d'oser
entreprendre soyez des entrepreneurs de
vos rêves
car il n'y a rien de plus beau que de
réussir
la semaine dernière j'ai créé une
association avec nawal bellour que j'ai
rencontrés dans cette université qui
s'appelle l'ascenseur social
l'ascenseur social parce que le mien
était coincé au sous sol et quand
j'étais jeune et malheureusement il est
en panne et en fauteuil simple et
difficile de monter les escaliers donc
j'ai attendu qu'il soit réparé pour
monter monter ensuite commencé ma vie ma
carrière alors avant de partir
j'aimerais vous lycée et voler c'est sur
cette citation de mohamed ali qu'ils est
impossible n'est pas j'ai eu
impossible n'est pas une fatalité c'est
un dc alors je vous le demande à vous ce
soir relever ce défi fort merci
[Applaudissements]